well gentlemen you've proven your worth
and earned your spot in this competition
but in this final round we're sending
you home for 4 days to build an iconic
weapon from history gentlemen we want
you to build
this the Napoleonic presentation saber
good luck we will see you both in 4 days
good
luck game plan is to do twist Mascus
you'll be able to see the a really nice
wide pattern in the steel
when you're twisting a Billet there's
the chance of over twisting it and
twisting it in two so I left it thick
enough so it's time for me to start heat
trading and
quench here's the moment of truth is it
straight or not
no it is
not that's
horrible it's crookeder than the dog's H
leg my quench went horribly
wrong it's
hard it's just got a hell of a warp in
it I don't think I'm in trouble yet I
can still reheat
treat I'm ready to quench again
I really hope this time goes way
better thank you Lord It's workable
there's a couple of little Wiggles but I
think I've got enough room to grind him
out I've never leather wrapped a handle
before actually come out better than I
expected it to I pull the blade out of
the acid and edch come out really
nice looking
good
now that I got it all finished up it's
time to sand it back and hope I win the
$10,000 I'm feeling pretty good right
now got this chunk of 80
crv2 because of its length I have a nice
comfortable handle to hold on to while I
Forge it I'm just getting the basic
shape and curve on
it so I take the blade out and I love it
it's perfectly straight for my handle
materials I'm choosing Hickory and
bronze for the back plate and for my
guard I'm choosing this nice piece of W2
steel this is going to be that knuckle
guard in this case I'm going to have it
probably flare out just a little
bit I'm going to do a copper wire wrap
copper wrap will also give a decent grip
with the the leather just got to do it
real tight and it will make it look uh
aesthetically
pleasing
nice and pretty I absolutely loved
building this thing I'm really happy
with what I
did BL Smiths Welcome to our Dynamic
kill
test Henry for you ready for this yes
sir
[Music]
all right Henry first up this is a very
light saber good job on that it's easy
to wield your handle construction that
gives me a better grip and retention on
your blade now your Edge man this cuts
and performs very well overall your
Andre it will kill thank
you Brandon your turn sir are you ready
yes
[Music]
sir
all right Brandon first up the
Frankenstein and his bride handle the
bronze you have here actually is
comfortable for my palm but your blade
is offset from the L here tilted to the
side so that every time I'm slashing
with this with the added weight you have
because you have a thicker blade here it
tends to roll a little bit every time I
strike but overall your weapon it will
kill best words
ever all right gentlemen it's time for
our Dynamic strength test the watermelon
and skull chck
Henry you're up first are you ready yes
sir
okay
think I made a
mess all right Henry Way To Go nailing
the weight on this blade scale on the
handle really well done got plenty of
room for my hand there's one little spot
that there's a teeny little roll that I
can snap my fingernail against but other
than that definitely a cutter good job
thank you Brandon you ready yes
sir
oh that's
terrible so couple things going on
grain's pretty big I mean you can
probably see it sparkling from there the
other thing is is there are multiple
dark spots where the blade broke so it
tells me that there were a lot of micr
fractures may have been quenched too hot
maybe not thermocycled quite enough to
bring that grain size
down but uh yeah I
mean well Brandon you gave us an
absolute slicer but unfortunately the
stress from the strength test did prove
to be too much your blade is now in
pieces and we consider that a
catastrophic failure we cannot continue
testing your blade I want to say thank
you for coming out but your time in this
competition has ended I'm going to have
to ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you sir thank you it's
bittersweet I think my main problem
happened within my quench itself but
Henry came out with an amazing blade
whole experience here has been awesome
it's been up lifting and at no point in
time do I regret any of
it well Henry the last man staying
congratulations you are a forun fire
Champion you'll be receiving a check for
$10,000 Bud good job how do you feel
surprised it's a beautiful piece it
performed well man congratulations thank
you it's pretty exciting it really
hadn't sunk all the way in yet but I
feel like my blade performed really
well the feedback I've got was great on
the blade and I'm proud of what I turned
in I'm Henry Walker I'm a forg and fire
Champion that feels
[Music]
great